STEVE: WELL THE NEW YORK TIMES
IS UNDER FIRE OVER ITS COVERAGE
OF THOUSANDS OF CUBAN PROTESTERS
OVER THE WEEKEND, DEMANDING AN
END TO COMMUNIST DICTATORSHIP
AINSLEY: THE TIMES TWEETING,
SHOUTING FREEDOM AND OTHER ANTI-
GOVERNMENT SLOGANS,
HUNDREDS OF CUBANS TOOK TO THE
STREETS IN CITIES AROUND THE
COUNTRY ON SUNDAY TO PROTEST
FOOD AND MEDICINE SHORTAGES, AND
REMARKABLE ERUPTION OF
DISCONTENT, NOT SEEN IN NEARLY
30 YEARS.
BRIAN:  HERE TO REACT THE HOST
OF "UNFILTERED" DAN BONGINO.
DAN, THIS CAUGHT ME BY SURPRISE,
WHAT ABOUT YOU?
>> YEAH, NOT AT ALL.
I MEAN, YOU WON'T SEE A TWEET
THAT BETTER SUMMARIZES THE
MASSIVE DIVIDE BETWEEN THE
IDEOLOGICAL RIGHT AND THE
IDEOLOGICAL LEFT IN AMERICA
TODAY.
YOU KNOW, THE GREAT ECONOMIST
PHILOSOPHER THOMAS SOWELL, HAS A
BOOK, "CONFLICT OF VISIONS" IT'S
AN OLDER BOOK BUT IT SUMMARIZES
HOW THESE TWO VISION, ONE ON THE
CONSERVATIVE RIGHT AND THE
OTHER ON THE FAR LEFT.
THERE'S NO OVERLAP ANYMORE.
DIVISIONS ARE TOTALLY DIFFERENT.
THINK ABOUT IT THAT TWEET SUMS
IT UP RIGHT THERE AND IN THE
REAL-WORLD, WE LIVE IN THE
FREEDOM AND LIBERTY LOVING
CONSTITUTIONAL REPUBLIC, THE
GOVERNMENT, BRIAN, DOESN'T
GIVE YOU FREEDOMS.
DOES EVERYBODY UNDERSTAND THAT?
THOSE FREEDOMS ARE GRANTED TO
YOU BY GOD.
THEY ARE BEING R RIGHTS, GOD
GIVEN RIGHTS.
THE GOVERNMENT CAN ONLY ENSURE
THAT THOSE FREEDOMS ARE CODIFIED
IN THE CONSTITUTION
AND THE LAW.
IT DOESN'T GIVE YOU ANYTHING,
THE WAY THE LEFT SEES IT, IN
THEIR VISION OF THE WORLD, IS
THAT THAT FREEDOM IS SOMEHOW
GRANTED TO YOU BY GOVERNMENT,
HENCE THE TWEET BY THE NEW YORK
TIMES.
AGAIN, THE TWEET SUMS UP THE
WHOLE DIVIDE IN AMERICA
TODAY.
STEVE: WELL YOU KNOW WHAT?
AS WE LOOK AT THE VIDEO AND IT
WASN'T HUNDREDS, OTHER NEWS
OUTFITS SAID IT WAS THOUSANDS OF
PROTESTERS, BUT DAN, ACCORDING
TO A STATE DEPARTMENT
SPOKESPERSON, AND THEIR TWITTER,
THE REASON PEOPLE WERE UPRISING
IS BECAUSE OF COVID.
IT'S NOT ABOUT THAT THEY ARE
LIVING IN AN COMMUNIST REGIME
FOR 60 YEARS.
IT'S BECAUSE OF COVID, WHICH THE
ADMINISTRATION BLAMES FOR
EVERYTHING.
>> WELL IT'S A CONTINUATION OF
THE 70 AND 80-YEAR, EXCUSE ME,
80-YEAR, EIGHT DECADES, NINE
DECADES-LONG EFFORT BY THE MEDIA
AND OTHERS, AND THE ILL-LIBERAL
LEFT TO COVER UP FOR THE STAIN
ON HUMAN SOCIETY OF COMMUNISM,
SOCIALISM AND TOTALITARIANISM
AND IT REMINDS ME OF THE SUBJECT
I DISCUSSED IN MY WEEKEND SHOW
HERE ON FOX.
I BROUGHT UP THIS WEEKEND, I
SAID LISTEN, GUYS, THE DESIRE TO
SUPPRESS HUMAN LIBERTIES LIKE
KEEPING A BEACH BALL UNDER WATER
EVENTUALLY YOUR ARMS GET TIRED.
IT WILL NEVER OVERCOME THE
DESIRE BY FREE HUMAN BEINGS
TO EMBRACE AND GUARD THEIR
FREEDOM AND LIBERTY.
YOU CAN USE POWER AND FORCE AS
MUCH AS YOU WANT BUT
EVENTUALLY, AS YOU SEE ON THE
SCREEN RIGHT NOW, PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO GO TO THE STREETS AND
SAY I WAS BORN FREE.
I'M NOT ASKING FOR ANYTHING.
GET OUT OF OUR WAY.
OUR FREEDOM IS OURS, GOD GAVE IT
TO US, NOT YOU.
BRIAN:  THAT'S WHY IT WAS SO
IMPORTANT FOR US TO BE
SUCCESSFUL WITH THE IMAGE, WITH
SOMETHING TO ASPIRE TO, AND IF
WE'RE TURNING ON OURSELVES, THE
RIPPLE EFFECT AROUND THE
WORLD IS UNQUANTIFIABLE, THE
DAMAGE THAT IT COULD DO.
>> YEAH.
BRIAN:  DAN I KNOW YOU'VE GOT A
RADIO SHOT AND PODCAST TO RECORD
, SO --
>> AND RECOVER FROM.
AINSLEY: RECOVER FROM THE
WEEKEND AND GO RECORD YOUR
PODCAST.
>> NO, I KNOW.
I LOOK FORWARD TO MONDAY BUT
LISTEN I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
WEEKEND IT I HAD A LITTLE RELAX
ING WEEKEND SO I'M ALL
FIRED UP TODAY AND ABOUT THIS
SPECIFIC TOPIC.
JUST REMEMBER THAT I'M SERIOUS.
THE DESIRE TO SQUELCH HUMAN
LIBERTY WILL NEVER MATCH THE
ENERGY OF PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
BE FREE.
NO MATTER WHAT.